[Music]
what's up everyone welcome back to the
lobby gamesbot's weekly video game
hangout we're here in helsinki finland
i'm just kidding this is our normal san
francisco set but as you can see we
uh redesigned some things we have a new
desk we have lights we have
four people on the show which is the
biggest cast we've had in a while and
we're gonna try it out and see how it
goes and then if it doesn't go i'm gonna
kick jake decker here off forever this
is jake
did you build this table yes cool well
no
i can imagine without jake you're gonna
have a really
big space to spread your arms out on the
desk when you really want to make a
point no i could put that was that the
lobby when we were talking about the
japanese uh body pillow or is that a
different conversation
[Laughter]
far away from me hi how's it going uh
good i don't have a body pillow yet
you have you two were talking about
zelda a lot before we started the show
and you didn't bring your switch in here
though like some nerd next to me
no i don't prove it prove it you have it
somewhere this is pete brown i'll never
tell you where hello gamespot reviews
editor i think still
that's what they tell me he gives all
that 10 out of 10 i don't know how to
question your judgment anymore uh anyway
and i'm mike mccarty your host and yeah
so we're pretty excited about our new
set we're gonna be still redecorating a
few things as time goes by but we're
happy you could join us as usual we have
the youtube and twitch chats up so
uh we welcome any feedback any comments
uh and i also have a lot of twitter
questions about our topics today and we
have a good show in store so uh looking
forward to getting into that but first i
have a few news items and i do have a
giveaway um we are going to be tweeting
from the gamespot account we have five
funko uh
evolve figures that we'll be giving away
evolve is uh xbox games with gold this
month uh so we figured it'd be a good
time you know we're emptying our like
our vault here at gamespot the nick
margarita memorial library
so we have five evolved figures uh it's
the four starting hunters and then um
the goliath monster uh and we will be
tweeting that from gamespot's account uh
i don't have the figures here with me
but we will uh you just follow gamespot
retweet that and then later on the week
we'll pick a winner and we'll send those
to you if you're in the u.s uh but yeah
i do have a few news items here before
we get into our show uh there's new
rocket league mode which i'm sure pete
you're excited about i'm stoked you said
you were checking it out it's awesome
you played it oh yeah you were at pax
you played it yeah tell us about it
quick so i mean it's not quick actually
take your time
i don't know i was about to rush through
it
i love talking about this game
so they said they kind of got the idea
from volleyball a lot of people wanted
volleyball but it didn't quite work in
rocket league which makes sense unless
your aerial game is really on point but
basically instead what you want to do
what no sorry
anyway
what you want to do is you want to
basically it's called drop shot and you
want to spike the ball into the opposing
side and when you do that part of the
map lights up once you hit it again
it'll fall away and basically how you
score a goal is by
spiking the ball into one of those holes
okay and it's pretty cool because as the
game progresses more of the opponent
more of the sides start to fall away and
there's more room to shoot
and after each goal like if i score a
goal on you then your side gets fixed
but mine doesn't
so it kind of keeps games closer too so
when we played like almost every game
was like within one point we even had
like a couple uh
a couple of
overtime games but i was on the winning
team every once do you feel like this
has
maybe like more longevity compared to
something like the basketball mode or
the other stuff they've introduced that
has maybe got us excited at first i
played like five matches of hockey yeah
yeah like this stuff like sounds awesome
in theory and maybe even for a few
matches but do you feel like this
thing's got legs like it'll keep going i
think yes i i mean i think classic
rocket league is still gonna be the way
to play that's gonna be the way most
people will play but i think what this
has going for it is that
it's
it you'll have closer games you don't
need to be a pro necessarily because the
way it's designed that like
when you score your side still stays the
same right so that means the the other
team has a chance to catch up as a
chance so i think just those more tense
matches can
bring a lot more to it
so that is rocket league's drop shot
mode it will
our lead by scott butterworth is it
drops on march 22nd uh so that will be
on all platforms for all players yeah
that's scott butterworth uh so yeah you
can play that on all platforms in what
is today in a week 15th yep dang um so
we'll be getting into that i'm sure i'm
sure maybe we'll have an excuse to
stream it
uh also as of yesterday battlefield ones
they shall not pass expansion is uh it
arrived yesterday
as a free update uh a lot of patch notes
kind of a big update actually but it's
the first paid expansion and they shall
not pass of course you could play as
gandalf
from lord of the rings fame no i'm
kidding you can't don't
take my word for that one uh that will
be
available for everyone else to buy in
two weeks but apparently as of now if
you have the 50 premium pass it was
available yesterday if you want to play
that
uh apparently yeah it's pretty big but
uh we have the full news story on game
spot about it we did a stream that you
can watch here's spencer kaelin mulder
and uh aaron sampson we're playing it
yesterday
uh
seems pretty big from what i've seen i
have you guys played was the last time
you played battlefield one
i haven't played it in forever before i
played titanfall yeah titanfall came
along and took all my time up pg play
much battlefield 1 nope no but you can
it adds the french army and four new
maps set in france uh two new operations
six unlockable weapons four melee
weapons a new behemoth the char 2c tank
and the trench raider elite class and
also a new mode called front lines
uh so yeah you could check out we did uh
like i said you're watching our stream
here on
uh the lobby footage right now you can
watch that we are captain we also have
more coverage about it if you want to
know more about it you can go read our
new story on gamespot.com
cool uh also something i'm excited about
resident evil revelations is the next
entry in the resident evil series coming
to xbox one ps4 uh earlier
no sorry last year resume 456 kind of
periodically released for ps4 um and
xbox one and now revelations the uh
which follows jill valentine
through that freighter uh previously
just nintendo 3ds entry from 2012 if i'm
not mistaken it was ported to wii
and 360 is three and three seconds uh so
yes but now it is coming to ps4 xbox one
um this fall so i'm pretty excited about
that uh just to pimp something i do
every once in a while mary kish former
game spot producer and we are playing
through the resident evil series uh we
are on resident evil 4 right now it's
taking us a while but uh yeah you can go
watch it's called resident knievel look
that up on youtube
uh we are almost done with four we're
about to fight krauser if you guys are
familiar with the game
do you remember resume four
foreign fight i played back when it came
out on gamecube yeah it's been a long
time and i don't have a memory like
yours
[Music]
oh here it is right now resident knievel
uh this is her fighting uh salazar she
she's been getting better at this game
though no still pretty terrible
i hope she's watching right now she's
over at twitch now so maybe she's
watching our stream
but uh anyway so cool i just want to get
through those uh a few smaller
announcements now we can get to our show
the meat of it we're talking about mass
effect andromeda today uh we could talk
about the first like couple hours first
mission and intro i don't know how to
explain it we can get more into that
later uh we're gonna talk a little bit
about zelda i know we've talked about it
like every week in the lobby for about
four weeks now but there's a lot to talk
about with that game and we're going to
be talking more about behind the scenes
stuff nintendo released this about half
hour documentary uh three episodes that
we can talk more about there are a few
cool stories that came out of that that
we uh wanted to talk about today uh and
then ghost recon now that our full
review is out miguel concepcion give us
seven out of ten we can jump into that
soon uh we have jake here who's played a
decent amount of it i played a little
bit of it and that's kind of the the
newest ubisoft open world as it were so
yeah again we are here with you if
you're on twitch or the youtube chats we
have it right up so we can uh you know
we can have you join us and uh cool
let's get into it jake
mike sell me on ghost recon quick
because miguel's not gonna sell you on
ghost record do you you uh like i said
miguel connections review was up he gave
it a 7 out of 10 on gamespot uh we had a
review in progress up like the week uh
beforehand but you know it was a big
game apparently like bigger than miguel
expected a lot of us expected super
lot of content yeah apparently i mean
here's what i can say if you plan to
play this co-op with friends you will
probably have a good time it's still
janky
there's still a lot of like you know
ubisoft things like unlocking not
unlocking different parts of that
because it's all open right away but
you'll find intel do different missions
but if you play by yourself it just
feels like a not as good metal gear
solid 5. like yeah nearly as good metal
gear solid 5. that's the comparison
everybody's making and maybe it's
because it's this militaristic open
world shooter but what
in your experience does that have weight
that comparison
with metal gear solid five i think it
does i mean metal gear solid is a little
more wacky right in its own sort of
weird kojima way
while this is tries to be more grounded
but it kind of isn't at the same time
and it just doesn't doesn't have that
sort of charm not that it's going for
that i don't know it just like the
direction doesn't make a lot of sense at
times
um
but like it's very it's tactical like
you can choose how you want to approach
things you can drive any vehicle fly any
vehicle so there's a lot of room for
experimentation but at the same time i'd
rather be playing metal gear solid 5.
wouldn't we all is it one of those
multiplayer games that's fun because of
the people you play it with or like
is it does it do anything to facilitate
a good co-op experience
i mean i wouldn't play with random
people like that's definitely a way to
play i like it does a good job of like
putting you with games with other people
and like
i don't know like you can warp to your
teammates so that makes it easier and
you can kind of plan things out but
i wouldn't want to play this with randos
because they'll probably just run and
screw things up without that sort of um
communication it would be tough and plus
like
this game is kind of screwy i'd say so
playing with friends and screwing around
is probably the best way to play that's
just having fun
when i hear even when you're playing
with like a team of your friends you
still hear the voiceovers of the
characters that they're portraying
that's really weird and like they're not
even really portraying them because
those characters are like
set characters in the game like they're
your squad mates they're supposed to
have personalities but then they get
replaced by your
your friends who are just like random
crazy looking characters but you still
hear the the voices of your teammates
which is do they like make it sound like
it's over walkie-talkie in that scenario
or does it still sound like they're just
right next to you i don't remember i'm
pretty sure it still sounds like they're
right next to you it's it's really weird
it's like you take a place like you take
you like infiltrate like a cocaine
yeah hideout where is this cocaine
hideout just i'm asking for a friend
how's it compared to the division right
because this seems to be the thing that
tom clancy games have been doing lately
aside from rainbow six siege but the
division being a new ip was this uh you
know co-op focused uh open world more
kind of like mmo leaning almost like
destiny kind of blend of shooter and mmo
whereas ghost recon like you said seems
like it's going for that open world
emergence of a metal gear solid or you
know like a breath of the wild but
here we find ourselves in another open
world game from ubisoft how does it
compare the division like with your
experiences between the two games you
played a fair amount of the division
right uh i didn't play a whole lot of
division i played enough to say that i
think this game is very different than
the division i mean it's still like
similar sort of idea like you know like
military shooter sort of even though
division wasn't really military um but
like
there's no bullet sponges it's not
really a loot grind so much like you
still find different weapons but you're
not like oh i want to get that i forget
what the colors green purple blue
whatever you're not like looking for
like
rare loot necessarily
dude he's being yeah
just just kill him or move on yeah i
also hate your haircut
um
what like as far as the story goes from
what i've seen and from what everybody
said don't ask me what it's about
because i have no idea no i mean you're
just essentially trying to take down
what uh you're in it's a balloon
yeah yeah and you're trying to take down
the drug cartel which have you seen the
movie traffic or literally anything else
about the drug trade you know it's not
gonna work
um generic
uh south american drug cartel right yeah
that's pretty much it the bolivian
government i think today like it came
out that they've filed a formal
complaint against ubisoft for the way
they've portrayed bolivia no are you
kidding no why this isn't so i'd
probably be pissed too i don't know if
you guys remember but when i think
rainbow six vegas came out las vegas was
pretty annoyed with them so maybe ub
stuff just likes to piss off vegas
entire cities yeah yeah for watch dogs
too though everyone was kind of like
yeah that's about right
uh well being like a microcosm for san
francisco yes just like the dude jumping
out of bushes on a what's the bush guy
plant guy
in fisherman's bush guy
he passed away
oh he did yeah
there might be someone there who's like
taking his place with the original guy
an imposter there's like six people
lining up to
i shouldn't be i got the call honey
we're bringing up
joni she's ready it's her time um
but from what i've heard ghost recon's
ghost recon's uh dialogue kind of leans
on
frat boyish humor from what aaron says
yeah i will repeat like a lot of dick
jokes but like it it has like no place
in the game like and it doesn't make
sense it's like but why would you say
that like there's
it's really weird isn't there like one
like kind of like vulgar phrase that
they repeat like
throughout yeah sea holster which i
don't know what means with this like
well i mean i'm not going to say the
actual word oh
no yeah they say like you get shot
you're like ah holster and i'm like what
that doesn't there are two c words to be
talking about but yeah i know i know
okay i don't get it
that
like i don't know yeah it's not really
weird not really like an expletive it's
more of a name you would call someone
yes it's an insult but like depending on
that's not it like that's the one you
hear a lot and that's the one aaron in
the office likes to talk about but there
there's a lot more that just like
like don't make any sense at all he said
there was like a lot of like dick talk
yeah i was like okay
do you do you feel like the actual
narrative is
worth pursuing to get through the game
or are you more like interested in
[ __ ] your work
yeah i mean it seems like the way the
narrative is built is that you're not
really gonna pay attention much to it
you know like it's kind of just meant to
do at your own pace do what you want
kind of screw around like see what your
friends are doing like basically when
you join a co-op game you can redo old
missions you can do any mission in any
order
so they were kind of going for that like
like even with the story that sort of
emergent
please gamepl so and the story suffers
because of that which
i mean
i
wouldn't play uh i wouldn't play this
ghost recon because i want a good story
though like you play because you want to
screw around but tom clancy's an author
man it's true but
no i
don't play i don't know
means nothing is anymore yeah we did
that lobby segment a few weeks ago about
like
our tom clancy games losing their
identity because it feels like it was
your idea yeah are you on it no no i
think i called you out and told you i
told people this year no yeah we were
talking about whether we were talking
about whether we actually think because
rainbow six siege started off as a
tactical shooter and i think that
actually i like rainbow six siege a lot
it seems like they're kind of pursuing
these trends now and after playing more
ghost recon and seeing how the division
kind of seemed to be cashing in that
destiny
flavor of game
does it seem like ghost recon is kind of
pursuing other developers trends rather
than trying to set it apart from itself
i'd say so i mean i see it reminds me
more of uh grand theft auto 5 than the
division kind of like that gta online
gta online has become something
completely different now at this point
um it's very there's a lot to it and i
know people who still play it like can
vouch for that but
ghost recon just seems to focus on co-op
but it's very much like screwing around
like you do in gta 5.
gta online well if you want to know more
about ghost recon wildlands we have our
full review up on game spot miguel
concepcion gave it a 7 out of 10. you
can go read that we also have streams
we've done which we've archived on
gamespot or youtube you can go watch a
lot of video content we've done in the
game if you want to know more it's been
out for a week now
as of yesterday like a week
so
let us know what you think uh hit us up
on twitter tell us what you think of the
game if you've been playing that amid
all the other releases some of which
we're going to get to today but leave
your thoughts in the comments and we'll
try to respond to them
all right
let's talk zelda again let's do it all
right so pete brought to our attention
yesterday
that uh i failed to follow through
yeah pete comes up to my desk yesterday
says hey
got a good idea for a lobby segment
nintendo uh is releasing these 10-minute
episodes behind the scenes making
documentaries of breath of the wild
so i say cool let's all watch that so we
can talk about it
jake and callie watched it
i watched the whole i gave these people
homework and they didn't do it i watched
all 30 minutes this was third grade i
would put you in detention dude i went
to art school for a reason okay no no
that's not that you don't have detention
in third grade third grade you get a
pink slip they just uh they put you in
that closet where you can't eat for a
day
oh yeah i remember that did you guys not
do that in third grade
no
okay
uh but yeah so we want to talk about
that some cool stories came out of it uh
i wrote down notes but it's worth
watching i don't think there's anything
revelatory but there are some cool
things behind like the art inspiration
uh that's one thing i want to talk about
but just like how where the influence
came from because you know like
as great as that game is and like
fantastic we've talked about it pete you
gave it a 10 out of 10 you can go read
the review on gamespot
yeah uh and we did an episode of reboot
which i'm gonna plug right now uh jake
and i have been working on this new show
if you missed like daniel dwyer's the
point that's clear inspiration for us
more of opinion editorial show uh series
and then bi-weekly show
uh our most recent episode was on breath
of the wild and why
i personally think it's like the best
open world game ever made and it sends a
new benchmark for other games and i
think it does things that the witcher
didn't i think those things that mel
gear's solid five did not that they are
all the same game in any way but i think
open world games moving forward can
learn a lot from breath of the wild we
did an episode about that and it was
pretty cool for the documentary because
they talked about how you know like you
start with skyward sword right it's just
open-air concept
although it was kind of masking the fact
that the world below was very very even
for a zelda game segmented right so i
did watch a little bit of the first
episode and they talked about the open
air concept like almost at the start and
it's been something they've been trying
to capture since wind waker yeah because
with the open like the seafaring right
travel yeah but it seems like up until
now it's been hardware limitations and
the team size now not that the switch is
like a crazy powerful console but it
seems like just enough for them to
capture their vision and then they had
this the biggest team behind a nintendo
game ever
so i think those things kind of came
together for them here yeah and they
said you know they wanted to recapture
the feeling of exploration which they've
been saying since the beginning but
when we first heard because when they
announced this correct me if i'm wrong
link between worlds was not even out
when they first announced the concept
for breath of the wild right because
they are said when they announced it
that you will not have to do dungeons in
a certain order it'll be open worlds
like how the [ __ ] is that going to work
and sorry you don't even have to do the
dungeons right and we're like how's that
going to work and then link between
worlds came out we're like oh this is
cool like they take a link to the past
formula and show us how it can work with
this top down
uh but still we've never seen like a
truly open world zelda game before comes
out not only is it just open world but
it's also these this like physics engine
that you can i was reading through that
neograf forum last night the craziest
things you do in breath of the wild that
you a lot of people don't know
i think i'm like
i'm
45 50 hours in the game at this point
and i was still reading things i had no
idea what you could do yeah uh of course
there's the classic things like this
they said they wanted to maintain a lot
of the zelda tenets and that's the
footage they chose to show was the
chickens and kakariko chasing you after
you like knife a couple of them knife
one a couple times um but yeah they said
they took
when they first showed they did the gdc
talk a couple weeks ago and they were
saying that to show the concept they
took like this 8-bit original legend of
zelda look to show how the physics
engine could work with a the thing they
showed was obviously you get the raft in
the first game and you can cross the
river but they showed how like a log
floating down rather than this item you
get could help you cross the river and
then you plant breath of the wild and
it's you know you're chopping down trees
and you can roll the trunks or you can
use the trunks to cross these ravines
they said that physics engine was a huge
focus and they said and i agree
that in execution it ties into the world
a little more right there's this
there are these overlapping systems and
then like i was saying people come in
every day i feel like still after how
many weeks after it's released and we're
all at least like 40 hours and we're
finding these new things it's very
intentional on their part that you could
find new ways to approach the situation
well they tie into i think the most
basic actions that you do in the game
which is simply just you know tied to
exploration in general like you don't
have to wait to get to like say middle
gear solid five you don't have to wait
to like confront enemies before you're
doing the creative stuff right you can
be creative at any time in breath of the
wild and in the documentary they
specifically specifically call out that
they wanted everything in the world to
interact um and that's how they they got
that feel like the consistent discovery
you get um i mean like you said we come
in every day and someone found something
new or like like a moblin threw a
bokoblin at me or whatever it is um all
of that is because they put a lot of
their effort technically and um as far
as overall direction goes into making
things interact together
um that was one of the most interesting
parts of the documentary for me when
they talked about the open world i think
it was known before came out didn't i
think we had a new story in game spot
about how the geography of this hyrule
is based on kyoto
uh so i think yeah we maybe we published
something about that um or was it when
you talked to who did you talk to
recently uh so the three directors that
have been represented here uh
yeah but there's two other guys and i
apologize for not knowing their names i
actually wasn't really aware of them
until the interview
um
but i mean like based on kyoto was kind
of loosely i mean the thing about kyoto
is that it's just it's still sort of
steeped in tradition compared to a place
like tokyo
and so you do see like even when you're
in the city of kyoto it's not hard to
get to an environment that feels like
nature still has uh some hold on on
space
um so i think that's kind of what they
were they were mentioning
and one of the more interesting
anecdotes
sort of talking to them about like okay
well you know this made me think about
even just going outside my front door
differently like i was looking at even
just like twigs on the ground and i
don't know why like what is it about
this game like one of the things we
wanted to do was recreate that feeling
of being
like a child at school right like every
day you walk the same route and you get
to understand like not just landmarks
but like
what those landmarks contain
and so you you have this this really
deep familiarity with your environment
and what you can get out of it um
so that's not really the kyoto aspect of
it but it's it's sort of just telling
like how deeply they thought about
making even something that looks like
empty space
interesting by packing it with with very
subtle activities well one of the
developers in the documentary is talking
about how uh because he's from kyoto and
because nintendo is based in kyoto um
they he thought about it as like okay
i'm so familiar with this city that i
know how tired i would be if i walked
across the entire city
and that's sort of where that kyoto
inspiration comes from as far as like uh
the
the depth of the world and and how it
feels to walk across if you were going
to walk across the entire map which
sounds free and impossible
um
and so that was a big thing and then the
other thing i really liked i'm just
going off of like the kyoto being
steeped in traditionalism um
was they were talking about the art
style for the
chica culture like the ancient cultures
was based off the jomon period um which
is a period uh historical period in
japan that not a lot of people outside
japan know about which is crazy because
it's like
12 000 years long or something the
actual period that they when you say
jomon it's like actually four different
periods within it yeah or something is
that correct i can't remember now but um
the the point was oh we're taking
inspiration from something real because
it's such a mysterious time period in
our history that not a lot of people
know about um so it's not going to
kind of
evoke
you know connotations of any culture
that people really recognize readily um
i mean that's another horizon
comparisons there's lots of things in
horizon that evoke cultures that we know
and see today versus this is something
that a lot of people didn't really
know about before and i didn't know
about before watching the documentary
and so that's where all the smooth
surfaces and kind of the when you open a
shrine and the the doors kind of open in
that
we i don't even know it looks like jenga
almost uh all of that comes from the
junglen period
yeah it was interesting they were saying
also like when you're saying who do who
do they work with to like work on the
elevation of the map
and that's huge between the glider the
paraglider and the fact you can climb
almost anything there are a few surfaces
you can't climb but very few
like that makes the game
feel very different like the actual
again i say this all the time but today
actually it's not open world for the
sake of it it's like they actually
recaptured
the joy of an open world game in that
just exploring is fun i don't feel
overwhelmed i know there's two more
divine beasts i have to get and i know
there's a desert i haven't even gone to
yet i know there's like this whole
mountainous area with you know these the
redo the bird people up there and i
don't even care because i know i'm gonna
get there but i'm enjoying this
traveling it makes the art of moving
from one place to another fun again
where so many games design their open
worlds to funnel you into something in
particular like yeah there are those
aspects of the map here where it's like
okay i see a path or i see a canyon
but you just can go anywhere and find
something interesting yeah even if it's
just a corox seed there's that moment of
like
okay wait what else is out there if i
just took a left here and found
something random i could take a left
anywhere yeah
i keep getting so distracted like i'm
working on guide stuff and i so i have a
mission in mind that it has been
artificially created for me um but i
still like i take
an extra hour to go do something because
i just can't stop myself um and like i
think i said several episodes ago it
reminds me of that feeling of playing
ocarina for the first time and seeing
death mountain in the distance and
thinking like i can actually go there
like what i can walk all the way there
um and it's that times a thousand yeah
um
sorry what were we saying oh i was just
gonna say one thing i think that i think
peter touched on a little bit but the
landmarks are like so important in this
game and they're so cool because when i
went to talk to some people at city
project read about the witcher 3 a while
ago they were saying how when you make a
big world landmarks are very important
like that's how you get around
um without like just looking at your map
the entire time and this like i rarely
open my map because there's all these
landmarks everywhere like you walk out
and you're like okay so death mountain's
over there like i can see the rudo
village like they've got that spire over
there there's some towers around here
and just that kind of helps add to that
sort of immersion that sort of level of
exploration it also does a really good
job of you know it's not all of a sudden
a desert
from a grassland you see this transition
area where it's like oh it's kind of
getting these craigs and ravines and the
vegetation is fading away maybe there's
a desert this way or you see your
thermometer slowly dropping you're like
well i'm heading north but i'm also like
increasing my elevation if you're not on
death mountain it's just getting colder
it does a really good job of
tying all these areas together like i
know this river is gonna eventually lead
to
you know the lake so i might as well
follow it rather than looking at my map
and you can also you know like looking
through your viewfinder is big you can
set waypoints through your chica slate
the telescope and that's huge and i like
that
they didn't one thing i think horizon
did well too and
which mass effect does not from the two
hours of play and we'll get into uh it
was kind of reminds me of arkham asylum
in that i was always in detective mode
and then in mass effect i'm always
i hate pulling out that scanner yeah uh
zelda does a really good job of not
forcing you into the map even though you
kind of feel like you're you know you're
revealing the map but it's not it's not
like far cry right you could go to this
radio tower and then all of a sudden
these side quests all pop up it's
it's just showing you the land right
you're like a cartographer you still
have to find the activities there and
then you are deciphering like what you
see on the map and i really liked when
they talked about the behind the scenes
thing about their concept of link in
this uh i really like the idea that for
the first time you're not this hero that
was just chosen like you're not one of
the ancestors of this hero you are this
hero who you yourself failed in this
quest the same exact quest 100 years ago
and now you're back
like for a chance at redemption
essentially but
i also really like that they said
you can make link not really that heroic
in this game you can fight bulk goblins
in these underhanded ways by like
blowing up these barrels when you're
sneaking around or steal their weapons
first you're not this noble
charge into every battle with your sword
and shield drawn you can be this like
little dick you can also just just say
sorry hyrule and zelda i don't care
about you yeah and spend over 100 hours
in this game anyway like you can close
the book on this game without finishing
it and still feel 100 satisfied yeah uh
dan anderson on twitter was asking what
our opinions on the divine beasts and
dungeons are in breath of the wild and
we can get to that really quick but i
also don't really think of rather every
other
delta game i kind of judge by its
dungeons i think twilight princess for
as much
jake you and i were replaying it
recently and i don't love that game as
much as i used to and i don't think i'm
gonna like a lot of zelda games as much
as i used to of course because breath of
the wild came along but they're still
great for their own reasons and for that
zelda formula you know eight dungeons
you collect all these kind of arbitrary
items that allow you to go fight ganon
at the end or you know again whoever it
is uh did i pronounce that correct the
agony yeah yeah um but
twilight princess itself i was like oh
those it actually has great dungeons for
as slow as the overworld can be but now
you have these four
you know major dungeons these divine
beasts but they're not actually that
long the first one right like the i mean
i say the first but you can do them in
any order a lot of people did
a specific one first yeah yeah the
kakariko hoteno village trail kind of
leads you to la neru where the zora are
yeah but
i don't know i thought they're well
designed you know you can actually i
don't want to spoil too much but you can
actually mess with the dungeon in cool
ways yeah i mean that is the the crux
yeah of all these dungeons i like the
fact that they weren't too long yeah and
they're not filled with like oh you got
to find a key to open a door to find a
map to get another key and it's just
like none of that stuff which i actually
grew kind of tired of as elders went on
um so here it was more just about really
looking at the dungeon and considering
it for what how it presented itself to
you as it is and then manipulating it to
accomplish these little tasks
and i'm a lot less um intimidated to
start a dungeon like if i'm if it's like
11 p.m and i'm like i should probably go
to bed sure i'll do one last shrine um
partially because that gives you a fast
travel point when you complete a shrine
so that encourages exploration too um
but also they're so self-contained and i
always found
um
that
it
if i just took a breath and looked at it
it wouldn't take me too long to figure
it out but i would always be pretty much
always be satisfied with solving
whatever it was um
and so i like that they're
self-contained and it kind of fits i
play i've played exclusively in handheld
mode it also fits that style for me
really well yeah i just i love the
dungeon design or dungeon quote unquote
yeah bob jones the twitch chat was
saying he just ignored the first village
cockrico which is kind of your first
real objective of the few you have
after that they kind of just let you
loose i mean they let you loose right
from the beginning if you want to uh
once you get off the plateau which kind
of serves the tutorial but a very well
made tutorial in that you can i say
tutorial loosely because they're not
holding your hand
like a lot of games do now like a lot of
nintendo games for the past few years
have and specifically zelda games have
especially like skyward sword the one
thing people dislike about that is fee
your companion kind of like solves
puzzles for you
in some ways and this is the well plus
the intro to that game was like two
hours of yeah teaching you what a video
game is yeah i mean in retrospect
ocarina felt fast because you if you
know where to get the kokiri sword you
can go get that really quick through
that small labyrinth through that crawl
space and then you can go buy the deco
shield once you get 40 rupees but
that was quick and then you go right to
the deku tree now
link you're in these boxer briefs you're
staring out over this world go just do
whatever you want i mean obviously there
are a couple things to kind of guide you
but it's not
it respects your intelligence it's not
prescribed
but uh yeah so that's someone was asking
forgive me i for missed their name but
in twitch chat if you think like far cry
games
would be better without that you know
map littered with
side quest notifications i can't because
you can turn those off i think but
again i think open world games going
forward can look at zelda
you know granted it was a huge team that
made it but not everyone might not have
that and also nintendo was pretty good
with you know
i think a huge reason they wanted to
hold off because they said in the
documentary they really wanted to get
early 2016 release once like the time
came up but then they're like we'll just
hold off
i'm sure the switch release date once
they knew that internally they kind of
dictated maybe you should really sell
there's a launch yes
that was yeah it's a good move because
people are buying switches left and
right what i think it hit one one and a
half million sold yesterday yeah which
is huge and good because i don't know
what the wii u is at this point how many
weeks after release two i think it's 33
million over its lifetime which is and
now we're two weeks after the switch
release and it's already at one and a
half yeah i might be wrong with 33 but i
think that's what i saw it's impossible
to get one too so yeah i mean
yeah who knows but um yeah but anyway i
encourage you there like i said there's
nothing revelatory in that behind the
scenes doc that nintendo published but
it's worth watching if you really like
that game and just want to see more
about it also you should watch our
reboot episode it's called uh
what we call it
legend of zelda breath of the wild is
the open world game we need that yeah
that sounds right yeah it's been uh i've
taken a couple days off because i've
been playing mass effect andromeda which
we have we can only talk about the early
hours right now uh we'll get into that
in a second if you're here for that um
but yeah go watch that behind the scenes
documentary nintendo publisher we have a
metric we have a lot of
zelda content up on game spot so you can
go watch that jake's done a lot of stuff
pete's on a lot of stuff pete gave the
game a 10 out of 10.
one of how many like i think 12 or 13 in
our 21-year plus history yeah the
metacritic not to bring this up but it
was at what 98
right and now it's at 97 because of the
whole jim sterling debacle people are
pissed off that
he didn't like it yeah
it's still it's still
i think it's an amazing game go play it
yourself uh but yeah that behind the
scenes documentary she had some light on
it and like i said we have a lot of
stuff up yeah and actually to that point
the sort of some of the things
documentary is talking about working on
a feature still kind of just trying to
get it out there about
their process of you know identifying
nature in this game and creating it and
what they were thinking so if you like
the documentary stuff keep an eye out
for that as well is that from the gdc
chat with yes
gdc chat i'll be pulling a little bit
from the documentaries they just
released and then sort of my own
interpretations of what they've done
cool so yeah like i said that stuff is
all up by gamespot and will be soon and
we're still working on a lot of stuff so
go check that out
all right
this is gonna be fun because
i'm flanked well no it's not i'm flanked
by very
and i'm trying to figure out how to
preface this because
i've played a decent amount of mass
effect andromeda uh bichon luke sipki
who's on our tricaster right now uh
produced around this show has played i
think the most out of anybody
so scott butterworth has been home
playing uh reviewing it
i don't know how far he is in the game i
haven't talked to him i don't know what
he thinks about it but we can only talk
about
the intro and the first like open
world-ish so to speak segment sure so
like it's weird it's gonna be fun
people if you're familiar with uh pete
brown he sometimes can be
voice of
what reason
i think he likes
to
you temper my enthusiasm sometimes and i
have to temper your curmudgeonly
there's there's a common theme on the
show where you ask me if i've played a
game or a series before and i say no and
it typically tends to be just games that
i just don't really have much interest
in yeah so coming into mass effect i
thought right this is my chance to like
give this series a shot i'm not worried
about commander shepard and all this
stuff
so i'm gonna jump in and i'm really
looking forward to playing it so when
i'm coming in with my assessment versus
people who have played all the mass
effect games and are
accustomed to all the things this game
does
uh there are very different
conversations happening in the office
right where where i come in with this
sort of sort of fresh eyes fresh
perspective on this whole thing and i
see a lot of things that bother me
you're also like well yeah but that's
that's mass effect that's bioware like
okay that's what i said at first but i
played more of it
yeah it's getting harder and harder to
excuse some of these things it's not
that i was excusing them to begin with
but it was just like you were saying
like i was like all right it's bioware
it's mass effect like i was kind of
expecting this to happen but there's
certain things that i wasn't expecting
to happen that did that left me
disappointed even from those first two
hours we can talk about right now based
on that embargo that bioware gave us
it's it doesn't even feel the more i
played or
the more i played it it doesn't even
feel like a bioware game it's it's weird
i like the combat
but i don't like the characters at least
in those first two hours and i don't
like
the
writing you're you show up in this
different galaxy you have a world of
opportunity before you what do you want
to do with this and
you land on this
crash land on this foreign planet and
you're like there's this one quote from
this dude who is just pissed off and the
first thing you do you know you jump
into combat and
this guy's
shooting over and over at this
i don't know i don't want to spoil it i
love how you were concerned that i was
gonna be the one to go
the more i play and we're right after
this i'm going to talk about our
favorite bioware rpgs in general because
they
have done some great stuff in the past
to say the least but yeah you land on
this planet and
it looks cool and this stuttering you're
seeing i don't even i don't know if that
is the stream or the game
because this game is
so
this the facial animations it's i think
jean-luc just china he said it was the
game it is the game yeah that wasn't our
stream hiccuping that was the game it's
can we talk about how awesome it is that
they just like flail their fingers
and things happen they speak to it with
sign language and it heals their
advisors but it's
look let me get into it i feel like
you're struggling to articulate here so
let me jump in because i'm trying not to
turn on anything
i'm trying to remember how much i can't
talk about because yeah there's more
that i don't like past times first so
i've literally only played what we're
allowed to talk about um
i didn't feel because to play more no i
i i i
it's going to sound cruel but the
experience was intolerable for me i i i
controlling the characters themselves is
is such a frustrating experience because
it seems as though they were animated in
a way to mimic real life like momentum
and movement but that doesn't mean it's
fun or
even the
a good way to control a video game
character and again like in a game so
when i push forward and it takes the
character like half a second or two to
wind up and then i let go of the stick
and they're still kind of moving forward
and stuff like okay i don't feel like i
have really tight control over my
character that was kind of my first
problem
i don't feel that at all no
the character maybe it's because i
played so much for the witcher and like
sure character movement was kind of an
issue for a while until they fixed it
but like i
i i like especially in combat i think
the movement feels pretty good i do know
what you're saying it's good in combat
when you have your weapon out yeah i
will i will say that problem is pretty
much gone at that point but like i guess
when you're in tighter spaces i guess it
it could feel a little bit smoother but
yeah like that hasn't been an issue like
i have issues with this game but the
movement for me alright what do i have
they really push platforming on you and
here's this
gd scanner
technology it's not even interesting
like it doesn't give you anything
cool to read like
horizon i think did a good job using it
the focus the thing on um aloy's head
that allows her to like investigate
things kind of arkham asylum and they
did a good job of not keeping you in it
the whole time because it slows your
movement so you want to get out of it
and see this gorgeous world they made
and this
looks cool
everything i'm seeing right now it tells
me
it looks like a mass effect game you
know you're exploring these new worlds
you're in a whole new galaxy you don't
know what's going on you come into it
after i forget how many you're 600
something years of cryos 634 years of
crowds yeah
after it starts after mass effect 2 when
they send the andromeda initiative uh
with the pathfinders and everything to
find new places to live they don't i
don't even know at that point if they
know about the whole reaper thing i
really like the original trilogy i love
the original trilogy i played each of
those games twice
mass effect 2 is one of my favorite
games
and i'm not seeing the things i was
expecting to in this game i'm not seeing
the characters i like right off the bat
in a lot of mass effect games you know
well no the starting characters are
always kind of shitty but yeah so i mean
the the two characters you start with
for your squad mates aren't that great
like one of them i've kind of warmed up
to but the other one like if i
accidentally end up with him i'm
partying like oh [ __ ] and i like back
out and like reload and change because
he's just boring i don't i don't want
him in there
but the two alien characters that you
meet uh kind of near the end i think are
pb
track and drac i think they're way more
interesting like a sandwich um but still
like
the writing is still kind of weak like i
think they're interesting but still like
it's not even the dialogue it extends to
the plot as well like in the beginning
of the game there's a pretty significant
thing that happens and something is
thrust upon you and it just like it
happens so fast and and the weight that
you then carry does not feel like the
character's earned it in any way well if
you're playing a he or she whatever but
yeah yeah in my experience this game is
just kind of like guess what this thing
happened now you have to deal with it
and
the character doesn't seem to like even
like
care
and everyone around him they look like
they care for the wrong reason because
their eyes are creepy their eyes are
very creepy there's really poor lighting
on the eyes everyone looks like there's
just dolls that have like some sort of
like weird
like seizures happening yeah yeah and
again if you're just joining or if you
missed when i said earlier this is based
on like the first couple hours so
i have played much more than that at
this point and i think jake you said you
played past that as well yeah about an
hour past it and
i really really hope
that i will get to the end of this game
be like wow thank you god that it got
better after those first two hours and
thank god it got like it was phenomenal
after that's what i'm hoping i'm not
like i don't want this game to be bad
but
a lot of small things it seems like it
just
feels like rushed like we were worried
about like
you know like i don't know how what
might have come down from ea or i don't
know what happened you know there's like
studio shifting which happens in triple
a development sure uh bioware montreal
worked on this this is their first
uh game as a studio you know like from
there yeah i mean edmonton worked on the
trilogy i think that oh sorry i think
the like one thing that i mean we've
only played the beginning and i think
the beginning is very slow like that i
think it does sort of pick up and i
think i kind of overlooked the slow
beginning because
i know these characters or i don't know
these characters but i know this
universe i'm curious what they're going
to do when they get to andromeda i want
to know the politics i want to know
what's going on but i do understand at
the same time that this is like you this
is your first mass effect game and you
probably don't give a [ __ ] like
who these like what's going on well the
game isn't making me give a [ __ ] yeah
exactly that's the problem so it's like
talk about the ui like small decisions
that they seems like if they had more
time they could have fixed it's the ui
is just
it's so frustrating i really don't like
it and then it introduces you
like about it uh okay it's super dense
and it doesn't do a really good job of
explaining like how you go about
accomplishing or even managing all the
things that are available to you
like it introduces like very quickly
like okay here all these classes and
these profiles within these classes and
you can customize all this stuff but
like
i don't know what to choose right like
yeah the freedom is great but like i
have no clue if like what i'm making is
a smart decision for my own desires as a
player or not
it's
it's it's very difficult to feel like i
have any
grasp of what the game is giving me it's
also the fact that in the world itself
it feels just like i'm going between
these
i remember a big complaint with halo 4
which is such a weird comparison but i
remember like people are you're just
pressing switches and shooting people
that's what i'm doing here i don't
i'm going between these consoles that
will raise these platforms that i can
jump jet up onto this thing to scan this
glyph to do this like sudoku like
hacking puzzle and people love that
hacking puzzle though in our stream
yesterday but the ui barely tells you
how to do it uh yeah let's talk about
character creation
that's the first thing you run into in
this game yeah and the default heroes
are
the female i think is is more of a
heroic
face if you will like more of an iconic
look
the male looks really generic and
strange so you say okay i'll make my own
character you are given
the strangest looking presets to work
from
i don't know how it looks like so much
worse than the the characters you start
out with it's yeah i i don't understand
like that was like with the other mass
effect games you had like commander
shepard like the generic link commander
shepard but you could mold him in like
it still worked it still looked good
yeah and it seems like with this they're
kind of designed for like the story is
designed for those characters yeah and
their animations well when you make a
character you just feel like you're
getting like
i don't know like a cheaper version of
the experience because i made a
character i i thought okay
i like the way this character looks i'm
gonna go with that
so i jumped into the game steven
seagal's estranged nephew
the
deep cut what
i don't know
like one of the first things i'll take
one look at this baby and wanted
okay uh you can take him lachelle
okay sorry you're saying no i'm that's
fine
anyway when you make your custom
character and you go in the game even if
you think they look great
the like
the depth of field like changes in the
camera or something because the
dimensions looked way different to me
like when i got into the game relative
to my character's body
and the first time they opened their
mouth i was like oh god i hate the way
their face is moving right now i had to
go back and make a new character
people people in the chat someone in the
chat i didn't see the name said if
you're complaining about the presets
don't use them the character creation
doesn't give you better options look at
this it doesn't
no and and it's really bad and
everything everything is like this dial
like even if you're going through hair
styles and i'm sorry you know what it is
i don't know what generation you want to
call this if you can't make physical
beards on your characters if your beards
are textures
what
[Laughter]
what
that that is that is like a decades old
problem that so many other games have
fixed by now this guy looks like the
andromeda galaxy equivalent of dennis
rodman
like this is what he would look like if
he was in a different galaxy humans
aren't shaped the same we should do a
feature of people just making characters
and you just trying to figure out their
backstory
never mind what do you guys like about
this game right now because i i struggle
a little bit to find something that i
really love something i do want to talk
about i do like
the dialogue that i have seen like
i do i do like some of that like when
once i got to tempest
right the tempest yeah i was sort of
walking around there and doing stuff
that was cool and i kind of wish that's
all the game was for me but
what about you guys outside of those
things oddly enough uh i didn't think
i'd be saying this about a bioware game
but the combat is my favorite part about
this game
that makes me nervous though that's not
why i play a bioware game yeah and i'm
all for like i'm upsetting my
expectations like look what zelda did
they just they said their return to the
roots but they like kind of
that's fair upset the zelda status quo
but i mean that's i mean they don't have
to always do what bioware has been doing
but yeah just when the most positive
thing i've heard is that the combat is
good yeah no
but what about everything else that i
wanted
yeah because you said i mean we'll talk
about it a little more in a few minutes
you said nice old republic you really
like i love kotor it's not the combat of
that game really well brings you to it
whereas this game i'm playing more than
combat and you know you can change
between whereas before you had to pick
vanguard sentinel uh biotic or you know
engineer or technician or whatever in
the older games this you can swap
between them as profiles down the road
on the fly kind of when you're doing
your loadout before you go on a mission
and i think that actually works pretty
well it took me a while to figure it out
yeah it's more flexible you kind of mold
your character a little more than
uh then the characterization lets you
but i do have a question about the
combat though is it like good in general
and compared to like when you compare it
to other kinds of combat or is it just
good for what you expected from mass
effect it didn't feel good to me at
first at all i really didn't like it
and even the enemy ai behavior was so
basic it was like i played halo
basically 15 20 years ago yeah it felt
like the original halo in terms of their
behavior
has it this has not been 20 years
halo was 2001
500 15 15 or 2015
i think the combat is good and i think
it stands on its own because there's so
much creativity in it um like i don't
know like they kind of showed it off but
like you can invest in different powers
and you can use them in different ways
like for this time you can actually like
like with a pull before you just hit the
button and they kind of like fly this
time you can actually pull them towards
you and then you can use throw and you
can throw them really far which is
pretty entertaining and like
there's a lot of cool different
abilities that you can use so that is
one thing i do like i do like the combat
i do like
the exploration in the worlds you visit
i don't like pulling out your little
thing and scanning it but i think the
settings are really cool looking which
is something that i think people will be
very happy with because people who
played mass effect 1 it was like you can
land on different planets and you'd land
on a planet and they'd just be a
different color i do like driving the
nomad and that's another thing driving
the nomad is actually
it feels pretty good it's infinitely
better than the mako um one weird thing
is that you have to like turn on
all-wheel drive i mean i i don't know
some people might like that but i
actually like hit a hill and like you
can't go up and you have to turn it on
and then go up what year is this
i call it six-wheel drive i actually
don't mind that it's more
you can also like drop these mines to
uh shift gears for you oh i thought
you're gonna do the gimli quote a mine
they call it
uh yeah you can do these little like
hops but it's fun like you can drive
straight over rocks this looks cool to
me like it looks kind of like i don't
know i just i love the
like there's actually there seems like
there's actually character to these
planets um there's a whole lot going on
necessarily like there are side missions
in like points of interest but because
they're sort of
you know like uninhabited uninhabited
planets there's not a whole lot going on
but i i think the worlds are interesting
i'm excited to explore more of them yeah
uh
i want to get to a couple questions on
twitter quick before we go into the next
segment uh so scott like i said scott
butterworth gamespot editors at home
right now playing it and he has i'm sure
he has much more in-depth thoughts about
this game than we do i know he's been
plugging away at it
i'm telling jake for some reason i'm
looking forward to playing more
and that's not something i want to say
same with me like it's weird for some
reason i want to play more of this game
and i don't know why i was playing it
last night and i like kind of didn't
really want to play it that much like i
was like i should just go to bed i don't
want to it wasn't keeping me up all
night but now
you went to bed and played zelda in bed
a little bit maybe yeah well empty
vessel on empty oh i get it empty vessel
on youtube was saying they complained
nothing is explained but with zelda they
love that there's no handholding and the
ability to explore your heart's content
mass effect
you can't move forward in this game
without these things being explained
it's like zelda doesn't gate you from
moving forward if you don't know how to
do something it tells you in intelligent
ways later on like 50 hours into the
game you can figure out these cool
things you didn't know you could do in
mass effect you can't progress unless
you know where this console is that you
have to press a button on that's going
to raise this platform to scan this
glyph before you do that another seven
times you can't move forward in this
game
unless these things are explained and
they don't do a good job of explaining
it i don't need them to give me a text
box which is what they do if you dig
enough for it through this codex but
kodak sorry um mass effect people are
going to be pissed i just said codex so
you corrected yourself so you're okay
i'm fine um you can't
it's i'm moving from these consoles
between these consoles to press buttons
and
yeah the worlds are cool so i'm looking
forward to seeing more of these planets
uh from the first two hours we've seen
um eos and the
the tempest is your ship it's like it's
the new versus the normandy and then
the you come in on the human arc and
then there's an arc for each race
but yeah the nexus is the like new
citadel and i didn't find it that
interesting so you like
i don't like the fact that you are gated
by like oh hit the button on this
console and then jump here and then hit
the button on the next console i don't
like that i don't mind that
i don't mind that it's not open right
away like zelda obviously like that that
doesn't bug me i don't mind that i am
gated i just don't like the reasons i am
gated if that makes sense like if they
found a good way to kind of tie that in
like okay and i think they did with mass
effect one and two like the way you
progress or one two and three the way
you progressed
made sense for the most part um and even
like one if people remember like right
when you get the normandy it's kind of
like all right there's four things you
need to do doing however you want to do
or however you want to do it and with
this it is a little bit more
linear in that progression but once
again i don't mind it i just wish they
had a more natural and realistic way of
yeah joining you from area to area right
i do want to get to a couple questions
uh
matus
mucha apologies if i'm butchering that
on twitter said is there any variety to
side quests in andromeda are they simple
fetch quests or multi-layered ones like
the one in the witcher 3. jake is a good
question for you because you love the
witcher 3 for that reason i i mean i
haven't played a lot of the uh side
quests but i do think they
they are much better than they were in
mass effect 1 and 2. it's not like it's
not like
very simple sort of like even three had
like somewhere you'd like be in the
citadel and you talk to this guy and be
like oh talk to this guy you talk to
that guy and you finish it
like there is more there's a story to a
lot of these but they do have additional
quests yeah like literally that's what
they're called yeah it's a section for
like if you're bored
so they do yeah they do have quests like
that um to the extent of the witcher 3
no
like definitely not uh so yeah matus
thank you for your question uh charlotte
cuts asks do you think that the
criticisms of how graphically polished
the characters are in andromeda are
justified yes absolutely i think it's an
artistic choice as well that just does
not land
i i mean i
this is probably my biggest issue is i
mean like i don't sound shallow that i
just care about the graphics but
presentation was huge in mass effect 1 2
and 3. like it doesn't look great now
but at the time i remember like with the
whole dialogue wheel and
the characters you talked to it it
looked great and
i felt like they kept pushing that all
the way to three and this one it's just
like
this is what this is next generation
this is what it looks like like some of
the textures and characters looks better
in three i think there's a lot of
similarities to something like fallout 4
um in terms of presentation where it
does feel like right this doesn't belong
in this generation something something
is amiss here um
having played fallout 4 i can like kind
of understand maybe why that is although
like even though i gave it a nine like i
still think the game could look a lot
better
it's the things i'm seeing in in this
game that looks so good in comparison to
the characters that makes me wonder like
well wait why
why wasn't that that generosity at least
spread a little bit further across the
game like the the planets you go to look
pretty cool the art direction like in
the normandy and or not the normandy
excuse me in the tempest like that
stuff's pretty cool i'd say but
the characters fell flat um one thing
has been bothering me a lot if the
characters have dead eyes how does
they're almost too alive
they flutter every once in a while it
makes like romancing must be so awkward
that's just what i've been thinking
about i just keep thinking about that
just go for the aliens yeah do they have
normal eyes
the ones well the ones that don't have
solarians with the giant eyes look more
normal than human beings yeah
um so charlotte cuts thank you for your
question uh and then once i was a little
light on twitter said does andromeda's
writing and tone remain childish or does
it develop as the game goes on and the
characters grow okay there
there is one instance where we'll talk
about eyes and we're talking about humor
that i don't know if anyone else caught
it but like i was watching you play
yesterday i was like did you see the
asari's eyes just now and you're like
what no did the cut scene really early
on with is it ansari or asari sorry like
okay that's like i thought you were
thinking of aziz
i'm always thinking of aziz it's pretty
funny uh there's there's like a scene
where something like really serious is
happening and it's like really early in
the game
and right before it cuts away the asari
like like rolls her eyes in this super
comedic fashion and i don't know if it's
like a glitch of like the eye tracking
or not to come out of her head but i
almost i i actually can't wait to put a
gif of that online because i think it's
super strange
all right unintentional humor yeah so
that's the tone is pretty similar to the
other ones though so those are our early
impressions of mass effect andromeda
like i said i've played more than those
first two hours um
scott butterworth will have his review
up monday yes sir uh march 20th it
releases on the 21st uh if you have
early access ea early access you could
play what we were just talking about
right now right tomorrow yes tomorrow
thursday march
16th 16th thank you uh so yeah we'll
have we have more mass effect stuff
coming out uh on gamespot uh we will be
talking more about andromeda as the days
go by and we approach the embargo on
monday and then we'll have more stuff up
around when the game releases next week
and i'm sure we'll talk more about it uh
next week doing a live stream 201 of the
multiplayer multiplayer massive
andromeda live stream today here at
gamespot at one o'clock in about an hour
two o'clock two o'clock two o'clock john
luke just voice of god told us some
strange man in our rafters just told us
that the stream is at two o'clock so
stick around for that it's gonna fall on
the table um all right
so kelly you didn't get to play much
mass effect andromeda but
you're a big nice little public fan so i
wanna have you talk about that a lot and
uh i just wanna talk about our favorite
bioware rpgs because
i feel like i just
was really negative about mass effect
andromeda the more i play it um
sorry those first two hours i was
negative about um but bioware has done
some fantastic stuff and this isn't the
same studio this is a new studio bioware
montreal composed of like different
parts of bioware
the canadian parts
yeah nice
nicely done i'm not i'm not that
familiar with the yeah um but
they've done some cool stuff in the past
so i think we each have games we could
talk about um but cali nice little
republic i know a lot of people like
this game i love this game but why do
you love this game um oh my it's okay so
to start off i think that uh it hasn't
aged necessarily very well i
i would like to preface uh what i'm
about to say but i remember first
playing it on
x the original xbox oh my god what year
is it um
and
uh i just i liked being able to
like at the time i had just like gotten
into star wars also so i liked being
able to explore the the extended univ i
mean is it canon i don't even know um
i'm not super big into star wars as you
can probably tell
but i like being able to explore the
universe um on my own terms mostly and
i just really liked the structure like
the structure of choice um and something
i hadn't seen in a game before really
that i'd played um
and i've been looking for something from
bioware to kind of recapture how that
made me feel
and i can't get that from kotor anymore
i downloaded it on my pc and i was like
this game looks horrible i can't play
this anymore right there of the myriad
star wars
properties on video games this is one of
those that people always say is
did the property justice it absolutely
does i actually really enjoyed the old
republic the mmo that they developed a
couple years back um i had to do some
guides for it and i found myself
actually just playing it for fun which i
didn't expect at all yeah i dabbled in
it a little bit um but
again it was just like i was searching
for the kotor feeling and i just
couldn't get it good god mang on twitch
just said this game doesn't look that
much worse than andromeda oh
man that's not true i didn't see it's
not true it looks pretty bad now i
played on my mac like two years ago that
was the most recent playthrough yeah i
mean
my memory of it is
in much higher fidelity than it actually
is
um
yeah it's
it's hard to say because it's it's in
retrospect i think that there's a lot of
things it doesn't do very well right but
at the time um
having uh the
what i felt was like super open
exploration and like story choice and a
story that i found interesting was all
really new to me um and i just want to
get that back
did you play two
did you like it
yeah i like two i mean my memory my
memory of two is more hazy actually it's
obsidian though right yeah yeah choose
the better one
what do you say john luke says two is
the better one
oh man oh i thought he said 2001.
republican
uh yeah john luke skyped you just chimed
in saying uh nice dollar public two is
better than the first one so tweet at
him not me to complain
jake
what is your favorite bioware rpg if
it's not nice or public what's another
one you like mass effect 2 yeah yeah i
think mass effect 2. i think especially
i mean john leuken are actually doing i
guess i'm going to plug something too
we're doing status party on the citada
which is basically we're playing mass
effect 2 and 3 and we're playing in a
way where you kill as many characters as
you can and harder than it sounds i'll
never forgive you that is another reason
why i'm so impressed with mass effect 2
is because
you i mean you build up this team and
all of them can die in two potentially
and just the way the story changes three
the way all the different factors it
takes into account it's really ahead of
its time and all the missions are kind
of like sort of little short stories
that like it's a good way to get to know
your characters
um rather than a drama or you just kind
of like run into them in the world this
is like all right now i need to do a
loyalty mission with this character i
don't particularly like but i want him
to survive and you get this whole
backstory about why he's why he's
helping shepard why he's doing this um
you know and it it makes for a really
compelling narrative
um and i think i think that is the best
mass effect game and i think it is uh
one of the best games i've played yeah
that suicide mission at the end is just
yeah it's incredible the way they build
to it and the way it pans out and shows
you how your choices have actually had
consequences as you go through the game
is pretty awesome pete yo
bioware me i see someone talking about
baldur's gate and they are rights
bald is gate your gate's baller than
mine
did you like it no uh so yeah
don't die
uh back in high school i think it was
around 2002 or so baldur's gate two
maybe its first expansion came out um
and that was sort of my first
introduction into like the dungeons
dragon style rpgs uh and bioware's
writing um that game was very different
as someone who primarily played consoles
even though i had access to pcs like
console games were my thing but i was
really shocked to find like the visuals
though it wasn't like a 3d game it
wasn't trying to do that
uh
really great art style really great
writing and
depth to the combat system and character
you know creation and growth that i
really hadn't experienced before in a
game
um it's one of those things that i
remember fondly that i would love to
revisit
um
but those again those games are super
dense they're really hard planescape
torment
sorry torment tides of numenara that
just came out recently it kind of like
follows a similar mold it's not made by
bioware obviously it has brian fargo in
in exile entertainment yeah uh so that
game uh i don't know daniel starkey a
freelance writer who gave that review uh
gave it a nine out of ten and uh so i'm
kind of enthused to play that i've heard
some other mixed opinions on the game so
i don't know but right text heavy
classical rpg very very text heavy yeah
which uh maybe at the time for me when i
was in high school that was right um
i'd be curious to see how it pans out
now but um but yeah like biowell's older
stuff and then i went on to play
neverwinter nights as well like the
original version and that game was also
pretty cool i brought all that stuff
into a 3d environment i can't see the
name of that game without hearing in my
head torment tides of marinara
that sounds delicious the new italian
restaurant that opened up here in san
francisco that uh i opened it
what am i talking about it's just a guy
screaming and i get tired of all right i
haven't seen anybody mention this in the
chat yet and i'm
both
sad and
dragon agent excited to talk about no
jade empire do you guys ever play jade
empire no miss that one
yeah okay so that's
that's why when i got into mass effect
andromeda i was like i'm looking forward
to these kung fu
yeah
i'm looking forward to the characters
and everything the characters and jade
empire are some of my favorite uh i i
wish i knew their names and like this is
one time my memory will fail me uh i
played it once and the combat got really
repetitive because it was like actual
real-time combat as opposed to i mean i
guess they're all real-time but you're
clicking a it's more of a mmo you know
you use this ability and they'll
there'll be an animation that actually
attacks them this is you're actually
doing like these light and heavy attacks
and these combos and you pick a fighting
style uh like a kung fu style or uh i
don't know you can see this
how fantastic this game looked but
uh
i really liked it i'm amazed that game
even got made
like just considering the the setting
and everything like that and like the
style and considering it's a new ip like
it
it was really cool there's the dolph
ziggler comment that people say that
oh someone did mention jade empire mike
someone did mention jaden archangel 3371
thank you sorry i missed it uh he did
mention jane empire but yeah it uh
it got repetitive in terms of combat uh
but i liked it for what it was i liked
how
i don't know i felt like i actually i
thought because i played a nice little
public before this and then i played
this and it felt like they took what i
loved about nice little republic in
terms of characters and their writing
and they actually
brought it into this cool like mythical
you know like
uh japanese landscape and it was really
i don't know i really like a lot of the
characters from it in
i mean kind of like we touched on
earlier even when the combat in these
games gets repetitive it's not really
it didn't it doesn't detract for me as
much as it could in another game because
i am there for the characters and and
getting invested in the story if that
makes sense um was that your experience
with jade empire yeah um it was the
story the narrative of the characters
that pulled me through it if that was
just the combat all throughout i would
have been bored yeah just funny because
it was based on like kung fu so someone
just said why would you make the combat
and that bad
i mean kung fu is chinese not japanese
yeah sorry i've been biting my tongue
you can correct me
call me out do it time to do it yeah
because you have to do it so much
and then yeah people are mentioning
dragon age who wants to talk about it
jake do you play dragon age i played a
little bit of origins i played
inquisition did not like inquisition but
that's all i'm going to say callie do
you like any dragon age games
i tr i tried inquisition
i played the first game do you like it i
did yeah i didn't finish it though
unfortunately i was back when i was
freelancing and struggling yeah fun
we're not a thing jean-luc loves dragon
age origins i think he's dying inside
it's really good uh i like dragon age
origins i do not i did not like
inquisition as much i played like 80
hours of inquisition and i but i didn't
really like it that much i
played four hours of that game
i made a dwarf he was my character first
character in origins i played dragon age
2 as well didn't like it as much but
dragon age origins like i said
that was
one of the pinnacles of bioware right
it's
the actual the overarching narrative was
great but these like jake you were
saying mass effect 2 was good at these
little short stories uh
that you kind of get to know your
characters through i think this game did
a good job tying those together an
actual good story
um and of course you know you can your
choices have consequences in this game
as well
uh but anyway yeah i think mass effect
andromeda is taking a little too much
from dragon age inquisition and how you
explore and i'm not liking it feels like
an empty world even though i keep
exploring it
i've only been to one planet that i can
talk about
but i've been to more that i can't
couldn't that planet have been a little
bit more exciting yeah very interesting
that's what i'm saying it's a different
galaxy why are we yeah why is this just
this this same fungal thing we've seen
in a lot of
sci-fi now all right
uh that is all the time we have today
but yeah we will have more of mass
effect andromeda coverage up um
multiplayer stream today at 2pm uh like
i said the beginning of the show we have
that giveaway uh evolve is like free
with games of gold now so we figured
we'd give away some of those funko
figures they're more detailed they're
not funko pop like figures they're funko
uh made like
action figures they're really cool it's
like the four original hunters and the
goliath monster are those the figures
you walked up to my desk and said i have
more figures for your pikachu collection
yeah
they look nothing like that electric rat
uh but we are giving those away so uh
some a few times in the chat uh shiva
who runs our twitter she
posted the link but uh just retweet go
follow gamespot if you don't on twitter
uh retweet that tweet and then later on
the week we might pick you and you might
get those there's five of them and we'll
send them to you um
and then there's yeah like i said mass
effect andromeda stream today at two uh
thanks so much for everybody the back
sean lucky eric tay uh richard lee like
i said we're still decorating our new
set but this is kind of how it's gonna
look from now on uh so we appreciate you
stopping by as always thanks for the
questions you sent in uh we will be
covering mass effect andromeda
throughout the week scott waters review
will be up on monday the 20th uh so you
can come back and see what he thought
about that game after playing the entire
thing
oh i just see it changing colors someone
has a remote in the back for these
lights oh i'm sitting on it sorry
are you farting and changing the colors
in this room
purple not this room blue make it blue i
like blue reboot colors give it to me
yeah
go watch reboot
it's our jake and i working on the show
we did one on zelda you can go watch
that also mass effect andromeda
uh
wrap this up
shut up okay uh he's telling me to wrap
it up but we have uh the story of mass
effect coming up no this weekend uh it's
a documentary series that we've been
working on
uh the uk team and richard lee and chris
beaumont here went to pax recently to go
talk to the mass effect andromeda
developers about the behind the scenes
about starting over from the original
trilogy you can go watch that that'll be
up this weekend it'll be two episodes
they'll be publishing check it out i've
seen a lot of it it looks great
you can check out more if you want to
know more about behind the scenes of
mass effect andromeda but thanks so much
for stopping by today that is our show
we will be back next week as always 11am
pacific
daylight savings time
we'll see you then
game ran today
[Music]
you